j'ai rarement vu des scènes fille de
campagne où on essaie d'impressionner la
serveuse avec un bloc je dois dire que
c'est plutôt une nouveauté les réseaux
sociaux sont passés par là
d'un point de vue professionnel
c'est contraire à l'ensemble des règles
de porc d'usagé et de maniement des
armes donc de vue là il ya pas photo
s'ils passaient un examen ils auraient
zéro et le 0 2 point de vue là est
plutôt une note éliminatoire et on peut
peut-être ajouter que ça n'est pas légal
de porter une arme dans une condition
dans laquelle il apportait alors ce
moment précis son autorisation d'après
ce que j'en sais ne le permettait pas
donc là je suis entré sur le domaine
purement prochain je n'ai pas géré la
partie légale mais il semble qu
effectivement l'autorisation dont il
disposait à l'époque ne lui permettait
pas non seulement de l'exhiber mais
encore moins de la portée